[Music]
I'd like to welcome you to tonight's
class we're going to cover the Kings
gambit for a white and how more
particularly how to play it for black to
get an even game without studying a
500-page book by John Shaw which covers
all chapter all possible ways we're
going to focus in on just one or two
chapters where he talks about declining
the gambit first of all that the King's
gambit is from the romantic chest period
back in the 1800s and before that was
the favorite opening of all the white
players back then the players considered
it cowardly to get play for a draw and
they thought the wilder the attacking
and the more gay pawns you could
sacrifice for the attack that was being
courageous player like a knight on a
battlefield there was then there was a
guy from Vienna named William Steinitz
who became one of the first world
champions the officially recognized
world champion there were others before
him Stein had started out playing the
Kings gambit himself when he was young
he played wild attacking chess because
that's what they were played and he even
they invented a version of the Kings
gambit named the Steinitz gambit and the
Steines gambit if you you if you want to
torture yourself as white you play the
Steinitz gambit the man somehow could
win games with it but it wasn't because
of his open anyway somewhere along
middle-aged Steinitz had a conversion he
realized
that the gambits when you play pawn the
King Bishop for it opens up lines that
your opponent can take advantage of and
get strong counter-attacks against your
position and he realized that you the
more pawn moves you make you you have
all these weak squares in your position
and he developed the modern chess theory
and wrote books about it
he called his book something like the
modern chess theory or something and it
was way back in the 1890s when he wrote
that and so he said what you should do
is not play gambits but and he analyzed
the openings and figured out how you
should play against people who did gain
but if you take the pawn what you do is
you don't try to hold on to it forever
you don't weaken your your position
trying to hold the pawn you look for an
opportunity to give it back where you
get a counter-attack in the center
that's really strong because the guy who
does again but often over extends his
position and opens himself up for an
attack so anyway after Steinitz and
Steines started winning all the
tournaments and he won all the matches
he played for the World Championship and
the old school gradually died out new
players came in and they all played
Stein ances method and the Kings gambit
became a thing of the past there are
only a few die-hard romantic chess
players that still played it there was a
Russian he was a with global younger
than Steinitz but he played against
Steinitz and a bunch of tournaments
named chigorin from Russia and he played
the gambit all the time and his favorite
was the Evans gambit anyway he was
fairly successful I mean he was he was
about 50 percent against grandmasters so
he wants them lost them and then after
the next generation hardly anybody
played it and then world champ
in Allegheny when he was a young he was
also another Russian he was a great
attacking player he played the Kings
gambit in the 20s and 30s occasionally
just a surprise value and then after him
oh there was a grandmaster named torque
to cower from where was he from Poland
he was polish and talked to Cour
liked to play the Kings gambit and he
wrote a book called it was one of the
hyper modern school with nimzowitsch
Starks of Cour he wrote a big book
called hyper modern chess and in it he
talks about how good the King's gambit
is for white but white should play
Bishop to King to not Queen Bishop for
it's called the bishops the bishops
gambit or the bishop goes to queen bee
maybe it was Bishop to Queen Bishop for
and not Knight to King Bishop three
that's out talk to coward like to play
well after he went on then there was
hardly anybody until World War two and
some Russians resurrected it there was
the famous Russian after World War two
named David Bronstein Russian Jewish guy
he was extremely good he played the
World Championship match with Mikhail
Botvinnik and he tied Botvinnik but the
rules at the time said that draw the -
ich retain the title but anyway
Bronstein used to occasionally play the
Kings gambit because it was so
complicated and he could surprise his
Russian opponents and then after him
world champion Boris Spassky played it
when he was a younger man a number of
times but with him it was more just for
diversion to change pace and surprise
his opponents when he became when he was
fighting for the world champion he did
not play the Kings gambit against Tigran
Petrosian who was considered the best
defensive player in the world
so Spassky held that Kings gambit for
lesser players actually
and after that that was about it
Bobby Fischer published a refutation of
the Kings gambit during his career John
Shaw says well that's not really a
refutation it's an even game other
people have done reputations but the the
book that Claudio has he says if white
plays properly it's still an even game
so and if black slips up then Y can get
a big advantage so it's a good surprise
value so anyway the easiest way to play
against it is to decline it not take
that at pawn to f4 so here's how this
game is Hansen Lars we had to go down in
quality with the ratings poor Hansen
Lars is only 23 30 he's only a couple
hundred points better than Claudio and
myself and they played in some
tournament 97 called the TAS Rep Jubilee
I don't know where it is he played a guy
named Gerard Welling who's only 23 85
but anyway we're gonna use these because
they're the really strong grandmasters
don't mess with it for the most part now
the the standard move - for white is
pawn the King Bishop 4 as we showed you
this game they get at it what a
different way but it transposes move to
is Knight to c3 and Claudio was talking
about the V and the version of the
King's gambit it starts out like this
it's safer for white he Shores up his
center with developing his Knight to
Queens Bishop 3 protecting his King wha
before he goes wild with pawn to King
Bishop four so anyway black the
characteristic move of declining the
Kings gambit is the bishop move to c5 so
and then white brings out his Bishop to
Queen Bishop 4 and black develops his
knight to f6 and Hanson stills not gosh
the Kings the gambit yet he plays pawn
to Queen three and black knows f-4s
coming so he just sets up the standard
with d6 setting up the pawn chain now
finally move five large Hansen plays the
the characteristic move f4 usually
played I move to and this is the decline
and black just develops his knight
reinforcing the e5 pawn and the d4
square and white gets his Bishop out and
now we're at the key move for black that
I recommend that you play move six it's
as you can see it's a six there's two
reasons for that move first of all it
gives an escape score for your black
scored Bishop so if white white might
steal your bishop with Knight to Queen
rook four and this gives you an escape
square but it does something else if you
want to steal White's Bishop with Knight
to a5 he has this little check over here
pawn here he comes back here you can get
the bishop but you've weakened your
Queen side pawns of those pawn moves and
you can take the bishop and you just
opened up the Queen rook file and I can
guarantee you you're not gonna Castle
Queens
it hasn't black now Claudia would say
well with those advanced pawns I can get
some threats true but you would admit
they're weak squares in that palm
position if it gets to an ending for
example so anyway the other purpose of
a6 is now at some point black could play
Knight to Queen or Core and take the
bishop and there's no Bishop to b5 check
all right now that the two lines were
going to go through for a white
according to John Shaw there's like five
moves
wait here but the two that he recommends
the first one is rook to f1 because he
can open up the F file with F pawn takes
e5 and the rook I'll shoot down toward
that f7 pawn and help the bishop on c4
now the other movie that we'll get into
the next game is to advance in the
center with Knight to d5 now you're not
supposed to move the same piece twice in
the opening that's an opening rule but
this is an exception because white wants
to get the knight up then he's going to
shove this his C pawn up to c3 and
prevent black from doing the same
maneuver with night to d4 C and then he
can maybe move his Queen the King Queen
the King to and his bishop out and then
Castle queenside so that's one reason
why the Knights of the five movies
played and even though it violates the
to move rule it has the good logical
purpose behind it but in this game we're
going to look at work to f1 now the move
that John Shaw recommends for black is
to eliminate White's best attacking
bishop that bishop on c4 by Bishop to e6
now the problem with you could take the
bishop with a knight to Queen orc for
like I said but there you moved your
knight twice and you've neglected
developing your bishop you haven't
castled yet so you take the bishop it's
debatable that you've gained anything
because she spent moves to do it but
this bishop move eliminates the
attacking bishop and develops a piece
that was back on c8 so it's more logical
now he says he had the drawback you
could say Claudio doesn't like double
pawns
chess masters don't like double pawns
well I'm guessing but in this case it's
different even though they're double
pawns they cover all the key center
squares that pawn on the e6 keeps the
white knight from d5 you see that it
can't hop into d5 nor can anything go to
f5 the white square bishop is gone it's
the white square bishop that would
attack the pawn on e6 also the double
pawns since they're in the center they
can throw all the center squares and
they're blocked by a white pawn on e4 if
that white pawn wasn't there they would
be hopelessly weakest you could pile up
rooks on the e-file along with the
Knights and win those pawns
but the fact that there's a white pawn
that keeps the rooks at bay and the
pawns are quite safe and you can always
bring your queen up to d7 the Castle
queenside or Castle kingside
and you can always bring the rook over
if you need to support it anyway the
pawns really aren't weak and
consequently white does not take the
bishop on e6 playing for the double
pawns that's considered not the best
approach
okay you got a question go ahead what's
your question
wait a minute are you talking this
position now they usually do pawn takes
pawn because right now you see how
there's a triangle of pawns the double
pawns in the neighboring pawn that's
actually a stronger pawn position that's
why white this pawn takes pawn now the
two pawns are doubled and they're
isolated there are no other pawns around
so this is the weakest they can be well
but what there's nothing attacking it
it's it's not protected
you don't say hanging just cuz it's
unprotected deef well there's no reason
to move Oh black white can but the
bishop can repeat retreat in front of
the rook and then then I can't take it
and the knight would be on the side of
the board which is bad right here and I
go here now what now what are you gonna
do you can't move your you're the best
square for your Bishop is either III and
you can't go there because my bishops on
that square or you can try to pin the
knight but pinning the Knights not
effective because I can Castle kingside
in the werk protects the knight or I
could play work to f8 I could move my
queen up and I can Castle queenside
White has no attack whatsoever and look
your knight on Queen or four only has
four squares he can go to and two of
them are covered by the black Bishop so
the night and ones covered by the white
pawn the knight has no better move than
to go back to c3 you just wasted a move
with Knight a four and black wanted to
retreat his bishop now as bishop
protected not I'm not hanging or
unprotected so blacks better off for
having been chased there and whites
Knights out of play on the side of the
board
wait a minute
are we talking about right here are we
talking about here that's the move look
at move eight on the board it says
Knight to d5 that's the best move for
white you advance you always advance you
never retreat unless you have to what
does a four do what Knight a four what
we already talked about doing that the
bishop just retreats here then the
Knights on the side of the board again
with nothing to do all right
anyway black wanted to take the white
bishop but he can't take the bishop the
Knights in the way it can't take the
knight with the Black Knight cuz then
pawn would take and would attack two
black pieces the bishop on e6 and the
knight the only way to eliminate the
night in the middle of the board and I
it's on the fifth row you see the
Knights on the fifth row when you start
the game White has the first four rows
and Black has the next right so as soon
as that Knight goes in the fifth row
that's like an invading army in your
territory that's like a Mexico army
coming into Texas you want to take him
out so that's what that's what black
does but he has to take it with the
bishop and if white does Bishop takes
Bishop the knight takes the bishop and
white gets double pawns White's pods
have been weakened and his two best
pieces have been eliminated so he takes
with the POG and he drives the night
away from c6 again the night doesn't
retreat he doesn't have to retreat he
does the same move you're
talking about he comes in to d4 he's
going to trade off that night on f3 you
see maintaining equality we're trading
pieces and looked at pawn on d5 for
white blocks that Bishop see that Bishop
is no longer attacking f7 so you got to
say Bishop to e6 worked it neutralized
the bishop on c4 do you see this the
bishop on c4 is attacking nothing now
what's attacking a pawn on e6 but that
pawn is protected by a pawn so he can't
ever take that pawn and he can't he's no
longer attacking the f7 pawn because his
all his King pawn is now on d5 that's
called a bad bishop would you ever
you're out Bishop behind your own pawn
that's a bad bishop they don't have good
moves in the future black is doing fine
best move for white here is to open the
e-file and black takes here well maybe I
say it does nothing what does black do
what would you do if you were black
you can take it back with the bishop or
the pawn which one that's absolutely
wrong didn't I just tell you that you
don't want to block your bishop with
your own pawn now if you take with the
bishop you're not blocking the bishop
right so the right way is this way and
now that black Bishop is on d4 is better
than the white bishop on c4 you see that
the black bishop is attacking a white
pawn on b2 and attacking the squares III
f2 and g1 all in White's territory the
white bishop is attacking nothing of
importance black is better so Knight
takes Knight accomplishes nothing for
white it's a waste of time
and he doesn't play it now
he can open up the the line his rook
eyes on and he can weaken black's pawn
structure with pawn takes pawn black has
to take back with the pawn now notice
that that black pawn on e5 is not
protected right well you might think so
but look the black can Castle King side
and next move bringing a rook down and
attack the white king this would be very
dangerous for white to take that King
pawn he can't take the King pawn if he
took the King pawn black would most
likely castle okay okay I go with Queen
to e7 yeah oh right and no and you can
gasp Oh Queen side you're right Queen d7
is better because your knight guards the
e2 square which is and you're
threatening Queen nation I check how do
you defend your knight okay but you have
to admit you're defending whites
defending right White's
attacking nothing whites has passed see
positions
okay Bishop to d6 threatening Bishop
takes Knight how do you defend that
night what Bishop we don't need to give
the check the check is bad
look look look if I go here he pushes
his pawn up and attacks my knight and
Bishop I lose one of them so the check
is no good but Claudio's move attacks
the knight for a second time and what
white can't defend it conveniently the
knight would take it the black knight
would take it so you see you don't want
to take that free pawn do you not
anymore where are you gonna move the
King you can't go to e2 my knight guards
that square you can't go to f2 well the
bishop is on that line the knight moves
say to b3 discover check and then takes
the rook you can move in front of the
King and that doesn't help you you block
your own bishop you haven't moved the
bishop out yet remember you want to move
your minor pieces out which minor piece
is white not moved yet well don't you
think he should move the bishop
somewhere and once you establish that
what square should the bishop go to and
that's exactly what he did he pinned the
Black Knight to keep it from coming in
and attacking white and now he's got to
move his queen up one Square and Castle
queenside or he might play pawn the
Queen Bishop three and drive the knight
back Knight takes Knight Queen takes
Knight and then Castle queenside
very good you're not reading this are
you okay what does white do now that's
not the recommended move the recommended
move in fact in the game if you look at
the game move 12 as Knight takes d4 see
how it has a question marked by it and
see the - over a plus the - mean the
white is the first symbol the minus and
the plus is the black the second symbol
that means Black has a significant
advantage after Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight that's a mistake by
white the computer says well there's a
number of things black Adu number one
black could do he could drive the bishop
back couldn't he
okay what's that oh okay all right
now you'd have to move back here right
you drove here
well Knight takes Knight check Queen
takes Knight wait a minute wait this is
not right this is not right all right oh
okay okay okay okay
how about plain old Queen the King too
then I'm gonna cast the Queen side next
move
what does white do all right I Castle a
new castle isn't this approximately an
even game all right let's see what white
really did what the computer
you know you got a point there Claudio
all right all right now we did drive the
bishop back so from need be we can drive
it further right maybe we should play
something a little more reasonable well
we can't castle I if what would your
move be how about Queen to e7 is that
okay
he doesn't like that either I can tell
by his mmm oh you tell me what to do I
like Queen to e7 number one I can castle
and if he does Knight takes Knight I can
always do pawn takes Knight check or
something takes Knight I can do Bishop
takes I can I can live with that double
pawn on f6 can i i'm counter-attacking
on the queenside RNA all right what if
he takes all right look let's find a
better move claudio doesn't like we
nicking - how about Queen here how about
Queen there is that better
and then I Castle queenside and if he
doubles my pawns I can put a work on the
G file I blocked the pawn my Queens Act
even if he does Knight takes Bishop
takes then the Queen can come up to b4
and attack the the white T Queens if it
white castles Queen side the Queen can
come in that direction yeah and I'm not
on the e-file so don't have to worry
about any work coming down at me you
know we're not going to resort to the
computer yet did I show you what the
computer says white should do okay
the computer says you're white you just
take it
Queen takes white you'd liquidate look
he's on the Queen and he just took a
piece Black has an answer Queen here
check g3 Queen takes so he got out of
that rather nice didn't he now though
temple c3 Queen the III White has
nothing better Queen takes King takes
and guess what's bishops of opposite
colors pawns are even whites Bishop is
bad this is a dead draw do you think you
could win this ending for either side
yeah the computer says it's a and John
Shaw and his book says it's a dead draw
you can read it later tonight
alright so however remember our guy is
not quite a trick master he makes a
mistake here
Knight takes why is that a mistake
doesn't it just transpose if Bishop
takes Knight so anyway it's blacks turn
what should black do here Claudio that's
right and that secures a significant
advantage the knight comes in does that
scare us
we just attack the knight if he goes in
there he's trapped he can't go to g7
check he can't get out he has to retreat
and we just come here and we're gonna
block the file the with Bishop to f4 and
he's gonna have a hard time castling on
either side of the board don't you think
so who has the advantage now black I
told you White's bishop was worthless
behind the pawn whites Knights hardly
any better it's on the third it's on the
G filed near the edge of the board it
can't even move into blacks territory
because it's blocked by the g6 pawn it
can't go it could go to e4 and get
swapped off maybe the the King is stuck
in the middle the board and the Queen
doesn't have any really good squares
either well the Queen could go to f3 but
the bishop will block it and prevent
Queen takes Knight at least for a while
and the black rook is attacking the h2
pod so you're not going to have time to
if my bishop goes step 4 you can't move
the knight back and hit it with g3
because your rook pawn is gonna be gone
the computer says - over plus this is a
half pawn or more advantage for black
you picked you picked a questionmark
move Claudio that leads to a loss you
just went from a half pawn down to a
dead loss now guess what the refutation
is the Bishop to f4 thing blocking the
rug and if pawn takes pawn to just do
Queen takes pawn and then he's helped
you you could Castle queenside and he
opened up the Queen file for your wreck
right
well it looked like you were getting
something on the F file but that Bishop
to f4 is the good move all right
now white brings his knight in and black
blunders and gives an even game he does
pawn takes pawn
what should black do but in the
footnotes there move 16 he should just
grab that silly work fun now you can't
trap the bishop with g3 because black as
night takes Knight and if pawn takes
Knight Bishop takes pawn check and if
you do pawn takes Bishop there must be
something oh you can do Knight takes
pawn on d6 and attack the bishop and
coincidentally the knight protects the
pawn on f7 too so black is winning here
but not after this move now white does
get time for g3 right Knight takes a
knight it's still on the bishop black
has to give up a piece but he gets
enough pawns to hold the game he counter
Texico with Queen to Bishop 6 naturally
white takes to the bishop oh no white
take it taking the bishop is a blunder
because Queen to Bishop 6 threatens to
get the the white bishop which is
unprotected with Queen to Bishop or
check the move for white to hold the
draw is Queen to d5 protecting the
bishop and threatening Queen takes pawn
check you clicked the bishop up a little
bit later okay now I didn't figure this
out this is the computer now black
best move mr. castle giving up the
bishop but look he gets the bee to pawn
the rook can't even protect the c2 pawn
you see that rook to D and then we take
the pawn there and the working queen are
raking this white second row the
computer says rook to f3 so you can
shoot over and threaten work to b3 but
Queen just takes the pawn nothing Queen
and rook have the second rank Bishop
takes pawn and threatening Queen takes
pawn check mate rook to h1 check rook
back
Oh Bishop back and now there's no
checkmate because the bishop saw away
from the b7 pawn so we can block what a
pawn and block the F file and get I'll
add miss Peters out to an even game king
over rook here oh this is cute King here
now watch this rook check Queen here
King here and nothing better than a
perpetual check
well look at all the ponds that black
has and white sting is not in a safe
spot right and the white Bishop cannot
join in any attack so it's even why does
nothing better than a perpetual check
which position are you talking about the
one we were just at let me go back to it
the king has nothing but to go back to
b8 you see and the Queen just goes back
to d8 and the the rural injustice it's a
draw by perpetual by always checking the
king and black can't avoid getting
checked every move okay and if you
repeat the position three times it's a
draw so after three repetitions it's the
draw most reasonable chess players would
agree to a draw here some unreasonable
chess players good things you point it
out but it doesn't matter all right
however white missed the very good move
Queen of d5 and made the very bad move G
takes black gets the bishop back and now
black white pawns are horrible to force
white is six black has two four two four
six seven blacks up one but he's going
to get that white castle's
the a to pawn goes threatening mate
alright I'm I gotta go any further it's
pointless
he's got two four six seven pawns
against four three-point advantage I
believe it's an easily won game but I
will admit the d6 pawn is hanging
oh he can't take the pawn on d6 cuz it's
Queen to a8 check King up to the second
row rook takes a CH pawn check and then
the Queen and were combined on the B to
pawn so the King cannot find safe haven
anywhere and if he takes if he goes yeah
so that's that's about it if he goes to
the third rank black can play rook to h3
check and then his rookie and queen are
on the c3 pawn to right
well anyway anyway he is at least a
perpetual check so that are covered for
tonight thanks for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]